too many of you are not focused on the
customer Bob Iger comes back to Disney
at the top and what does he do he
eliminates a ridiculous policy of
charging people eight dollars a photo of
the photo on the rides you know when
you're going down a thing you're like
I'm scared of all that little things
like this add up he's focused on the end
consumer they've got a business to run
he's a public company he's got a stock
price I get all that but little things
like this add up a lot of us small
businesses medium-sized businesses we're
huge businesses like this have silly
little things in place that are good for
us in the short term bad for the
customer and eventually that's going to
piss them off make them go in other
directions so when big companies do
things like this it's always a good
opportunity for you to take a step back
and be like is there anything I'm doing
in my small business in my world that
really is for me I'm being selfish and
can I flip it and be a little more
selfless a little bit more Pro customer